well it is called Betty's Village the
housing complex built by Opportunity
Village for local adults with special
needs OV says it has been a success so
now it wants to build again Lauren
negrady is joining us live this morning
with the story Lauren good morning to
you good morning you guys that's right
Betty's Village is getting a sister
property it's 17.6 acres of land in the
in the Northwest Valley back in 2021
Opportunity Village opened its first 35
million dollar housing project for those
with special needs it quickly became a
hit and even back then they talked about
adding more future housing well ov's
presidents and CEO tells me they'll
develop the sister property in a couple
of phases with 100 more people being
served in the first phase alone
this is a a game changer for people with
disabilities and for families that have
people that never thought they could
live independently in their own home and
now they can
Brown says there's 400 people on the
waiting list the demand is growing and
they're working to get ahead of it he
says the second phase will see a
community center and most likely more
housing now they plan to break ground
come next spring on Betty's Village 2.0
and the construction should start should
take a couple of years there's a 10
million dollar match Grant we'll post
donation information on our website
8newsnow.com Nate just